hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about
reasons to become a software engineer
now right now so let's get to it
first of all if you're looking for a
sign to become a software engineer
you've been doing your research looking
at different videos
treat this as your sign just do it
if you have been doing all this work all
this research you're obviously
interested
and so really just take that leap and
yeah just
just go for it but if you need more
convincing then we can start with
one you have the ability to transfer
your work into your own
business if you're the type of person
who has that mentality of i will not be
working for another person
for the rest of my life not not for x
amount of years i want to just work and
then do my own business
well coding development engineering is a
great way to do that
because you can learn and then work for
a company for
three to five years really soak in that
knowledge soak in that skill
soaking that network and then go off and
do your own thing you don't even need a
team
to be honest like if you are willing to
grind and if you have a certain timeline
that you're willing to work with
you really don't need a team it can be
you yourself and your thoughts
just cranking it out and creating an
amazing business
that business could be freelancing or it
could be developing
a new app a new technology for this
country for this world to see
you do not need to be stuck to a desk
working for
johnson johnson and johnson incorporated
for the rest of your life
you really are free to after some time
after you see the time is right
to take what you've learned and build
your own empire
the second reason to become a software
engineer is because it is both technical
and artistic this is something that
i really liked i'm a person who loves
getting to the nitty gritty loves being
detail oriented and you know
problem solving and looking at data and
things like that
but also i like being artistic
i love you know playing guitar and i
love
you know listening to music dancing
singing like all of these different
artistic things
and coding for me is something that
really really combines
these two things into one perfect
child where where there's the problem
solving aspect because
you're trying to see how to best run
your app how to best problem solve
but also with the artistic you don't
even need to be a front-end developer to
feel like you're being artistic
because the artistic part if you're not
front end developer
comes from the finding and creating of
these solutions
to problems that you've never seen
before but you were
able to mix things together in such a
way that
you were able to make things run and so
with this you feel like an artist you
really do you feel like an artist
creating something from nothing making
something work when previously it didn't
now if you're front-end developer
the artistic part is more obvious
because you get to
play around with colors and shadings and
design and
user experiences and flows and is just
again also a very can be a very
beautiful experience if you
like it and if you let it be and so
because of this it actually goes into my
third point
it ends up being a really fulfilling
career you oh my goodness today i was
actually very happy today
because because i was able to
fix a couple of bugs i was having and
when i did when i clicked refresh
on that page and everything popped up
like i was supposed to i was like
yeah like i actually end up audibly
saying yeah or like fist pumping and
honestly thank goodness i work from home
because i don't know if that will change
once i'm in the office i don't know
we'll see
but yeah it's such a fulfilling career
one
that self-satisfaction when you get
something right when you fix something
and two when you know that you're
creating something for the greater good
when you are
creating something that users actually
will interact with that the community
will actually get
to see that just feels so good the
fourth reason to become a software
engineer specifically in 2021 is because
you don't need a computer science degree
you don't need them i'm not saying don't
get one this is not
i wouldn't no i'm not saying that but
if you are let's say you're 18 years old
right now you are trying to figure out
if
college is worth it because it's online
and it costs 50 000
or you know you want to be a front-end
developer
and so college doesn't really teach
that much front-end material anyway
and seeing how you can develop outside
of college
you don't need a degree you don't the
world's largest companies they will hire
developers
simply on merit and skill they don't
need to see a degree from you because
they know that some of the most skilled
developers that they have
and are in this world don't have that
google actually used to have a
requirement of
a degree before you applied to their
jobs but they realized they were missing
out on such amazing talent by doing that
they actually dropped that requirement
and so just to show you i'm not saying
that
oh companies don't require a degree and
it's just the start of like no
top companies top companies don't need
to see a degree from you what they need
to see from you
is skill now whether or not you can
truly get that
skill without a degree without
a boot camp without a program a xyz
that is a conversation for you because
people learn different ways
i personally and not a person who can
just teach myself
i wish i really wish i was like oh my
goodness the money i would save
i really wish i was and see if you are
too but if you're not there's nothing
wrong with getting that degree getting
that boot camp getting that certificate
but you don't need one you don't need
outside credentials all you need
is that skill in that portfolio showing
how skilled of a developer
you are the fifth reason is because
software engineering allows you to be
insanely
mobile if you want to live in mumbai for
the next two years
go you will find a job you will
find you best you will find a job and so
it becomes less of a concern
or less of a question of where you want
to be and where
the job is and having to you know find
the happy medium of those but
really just where do you want to live
okay so now get the job
and so it creates this possibility for
just a happier
life because you are where you want to
be you're not where you are because the
job took you there
maybe the job did take you there but
honestly if you don't
need to be there if you don't want to be
there you could find
a software engineering role developer
role
somewhere else around the country around
the world
and so it allows this flexibility for
your life
that can really just contribute to just
such a
much better state of living knowing that
you have full control of where you are
when you are etc
and related to that number six you can
be
also remote you don't need to quit that
job to go to mumbai
but you could be from a remote worker
and work for
xyz company while actually not being in
that office while
being at home a block away or while
being at home a continental way you can
be
remote now whether or not your boss will
allow it
is a different conversation i think
that's a conversation that
is a lot more possible to have now
because since the world was forced to be
remote
now companies have integrated systems
that maybe they didn't have before
and when we if we i mean oh god
hopefully one day if we can get back
into
normalcy again and companies are
allowing people to work in office again
if you want to be somewhere else
hopefully now it won't be a problem
because they have the systems in place
from the panoramic of 2020 to 2021.
so that is another reason to become a
software engineer and the last reason to
become a software engineer
is the pay it comes it goes without
saying
the pay can be quite nice the benefits
can be quite nice
and it can allow you flexibility to just
live the type of life you
want the average salary in the united
states goes from anywhere between sixty
five thousand
and a hundred and sixty-five thousand
according to salary.com
that is a big range a big big range but
typically you can find yourself in the
nice medium in between there
on top of that after just a year or two
of working your first developer jobs
you will have recruiters knocking down
your door and so if you are on that
lower end at first
don't sweat it within one to two years
you will have recruiters knocking down
your door companies knocking down your
door
wanting you and you will shoot up your
salary like crazy
the amount your salary goes up every
time you make a switch
is insane in the development field and
so remember
that and yeah again if you
need a reason if you need a sign
let this be the sign please subscribe i
love seeing this channel girl i'm almost
at a thousand subscribers so
please please help me out and get to
that
1000 but i'm looking forward to seeing
you all soon i hope you enjoyed
bye y'all